[THEME MUSIC]
JASON SILVA: So you hear
people complain these days
that everything is
becoming automated.
The robots are
stealing our jobs.
AI is coming, the
Terminator scenario.
But I think that ultimately
people don't really
have a reason to be scared.
Because I think that what
artificial intelligence
ultimately comes down
to, what outsourcing
our cognition into the
machines is really all about,
it's about amplifying the
most powerful phenomenon
in the universe,
which is intelligence.
We're finally learning to
reverse-engineer, distill,
understand, reproduce
intelligence.
Once we can create
sentience that is not
bound by the bandwidth of our
physicality, of our biology,
we will literally be
creating a sentience
that can upgrade itself.
Minds that create minds.
Computers that build
better computers.
And at this point,
the runaway train
that literally is speeding
up at an exponential rate,
will leave everything behind.
The human era will have ended.
We will have become
our creations.
They will be our children,
but they will really be us.
There is no reason to fear this.
This is just evolution.
[THEME MUSIC]